And earlier this year, we just, uh, sold to AppFolio,
which is where I am building out the product, scaling it and, uh,
adapting the product to their client base. Got it. Mind if I ask,
how much did you guys sell it for? Well, it's public, uh,
for people who wanted to know mine, if I do my research and put on my video,
I guess, I guess I can just tell you because you're going to put it on anyways.
Uh, we, we sold for 60.
Okay. Before we continue this video, I just want to say,
thank you brilliant for sponsoring this video everyday brilliant publishes daily
challenges on many STEM topics like math, science,
and computer science.
This site is extremely sleek and they have over 60 interactive courses,
which makes learning these concepts ways easier because of the hands on
approach. They also have a artificial neuro networks course, which is really,
really well-made. And I think if you're very interested in ML,
you should definitely check it out.
This is a great compliment to university because you can do practice questions
under well curated sequences of problems,
which allows you to master to top. If you want to master, you know,
I wish I had brilliant when I was in college because I'm more of a hands-on
kind of guy I learned by practicing. And if I had brilliant,
I think I would have understood these concepts a lot faster.
So if you're interested, you can go on
brilliant.org/joma and then the first 200 people will get 20% off. All right.
That's it.
All right. We'll come back. Thank you. Thank you. Thanks for having me back.
Yeah. Thanks for coming. David LA light brother. Cool.
I think I'm your first, uh,
interview that came back for a second round in way am my right.
I think you are actually. Yeah. Yeah. Interesting.
Because you were high in demand, so I had to bring it back. Okay, cool.
So just a little context in the previous video,
I made an interview with you and it's mostly about how you were a quantity at
two Sigma,
and then that video you told me that you quit your job to do
to co-found a startup. Is that correct? Yep. So a lot of people were wondering,
why did you make the switch? The switch? There was a lot of small reasons, um,
wanting to try something new, um, wanting to see what was out there for,
uh, deep learning. I wanted to also look at cryptocurrencies.
I want to look at biotech. Um, but in the end, uh, Elliot,
the co-founder of dynasty, uh,
reached out to me like a week after, uh, I said I was going to quit.
And he was like, Hey, have you ever thought about quitting? And I was like,
dude, I quit like one week ago. Hi, how do you, how did you, how'd you do this?
And then, then he said like, yeah, just come out to LA and then, uh,
see what we're doing. And then, uh, there's nothing, no harm done. Right. God,
I, one thing led to the next and you know, here I am now. Nice. Nice.
So between back then, when I interviewed to now.
Any updates on the startup is dynasty, right?
Yeah. There was a lot, a lot, a lot, a lot happened since, uh,
since the last time we spoke, um, I joined dynasty at that time,
we had just pivoted into, um, the,
the AI for, for real estate, uh, business.
And during that time, uh, we built a product found product market fit.
Um, and earlier this year we just, uh,
sold to AppFolio and which is where I am building out the product,
scaling it and, uh, adapting the product to their clients.
Got it. Mind if I ask, how much did you guys sell it for?
Well, it's public, uh, for people who want to, to know.
Mind if I do my research and put on my video.
I guess, I guess I can just tell you because you're going to put it on anyways.
Uh, w we sell for 60 million. Yeah.
Nice. How many co-founders are you guys?
So dynasty was initially a different business, which did not succeed. Uh,
and that's very, that's very common for, um, a lot of startups. Uh, so we,
at the end of the last business, everything was, we were like 10 people.
Uh, and I joined that as like the six person. Um, and at that time,
things were not going well. The,
there was no product market fits and we started pivoting into the AI
for real estate and, uh, about half the people left. Oh.
So in terms of co-founder originally there were two co-founders and then,
uh, this new, well for the new pivot, uh, five of us were left.
Yeah.
Just a TLDR. What was the previous product and what is the product now,
just to make it more clear.
Um, back then we wanted to create, we wanted to securitize, uh,
real estate assets, um, basically create a,
an exchange and then allowing people with a smaller amount of
capital to, uh, taken, take positions in real estate assets.
If you think about it right now, you have to buy a house. You have to have,
you know, especially in, uh, Silicon Valley,
you have to have like 200 K 300 K just to put it put down a,
a deposit it's not very democratic, right. And also your,
all your money is into this one single assets.
That's very susceptible to, um,
to local changes. Uh,
so we wanted to change that it didn't really work out. Uh, we,
at least we didn't find how to make it work. Uh,
I'm not going to say it's a bad idea because we still think that, you know,
there are benefits to this world we're dreaming of. Um,
but in the process, Elliots and other, uh,
people who joined before me found out that a lot of real estate participants
had a lot of trouble managing their assets. So it's unlike stocks,
real estate is a as an asset that you have to, you know,
it's a real thing you have to keep. Yeah, there's up cave. You want to like,
get people into it for rentals and stuff like that.
I think half of the income comes from, uh, rentals. Right?
If you take it, the other half has appreciation.
So one of the big challenges was the operations of leasing
a building or leasing, uh, your assets. So we decided, well,
everybody says, it's a problem. So let's do something about it. Yeah. And that,
that's where, uh, Lisa came in,
Lisa is the second iteration of dynasty. So.
That's like the pivot, that's your new business. That's.
Right. Yeah. And of course, Lisa is an AI for leasing.
The fun.
I was wondering now that you've, you know, dig your hands deep into ML.
Are there any misconceptions about ML engineering that you want to debunk?
I think the, the general, uh,
excitement about ML is great. It made a lot of people go into ML that,
and that's awesome, but like a lot of focus has been on, uh,
how do I build models and how do I, uh, fit, uh,
fit a model to the data. But like very little focus has been, uh,
on how do I generate data?
How do I design a business process that will create data for the algorithm
that I want to build? How do I handle the outputs?
How do I build all the process around, uh,
DML components that there's too much focus on building the models? Uh,
not in the focus on how to integrate, uh,
ML into existing, uh, products and to be fair,
it's kind of a new field, right? Um,
not many people have to know how to do this because it's, it's, it's so new. Uh,
like an analogy is when, you know,
computers were first invented or like the internet was first invented.
People were finding out how to integrate that into existing business processes.
And, you know, it took a lot of trial and error, but that's the same thing.
Like not everything is just building up.
Right? Yeah.
Not everything becomes more useful if there's machine learning in it. Yeah.
Right. Maybe not everything should use blockchain technology. Exactly. Right.
That's what, that's the example I wanted to use. Like,
I always wonder a lot of people want to do machine learning. Now my viewers,
especially because I think it's because I'm in the intersection of data science
and software engineering, but, um,
I don't wan I don't really understand the appeal of machine learning at the job
because in my mind what you do is like you said,
you make sure you have good data, make sure you solve a problem with your ML.
So most of the time in my head,
you build data pipelines to funnel into your model. You pick a model,
you play with the,
you tune the parameters and then try to optimize for that AUC.
And then that's it like is, or is there more to it that I don't know?
That is fun. I think.
Like, you're, you're kind of right. I mean,
especially if you're building products, you know,
you don't have the time to do the fun stuff. And in ML research,
the way I see it, software engineering is the core skill.
And then there's like ML engineering that, that gives you a bit more,
um, domain knowledge into how to build ML products or ML
models. But in the end, once you, once you've done that, like a V1 of it,
that's it, you have to, you have to build all of the systems around it. Uh,
and that's not what the school, uh,
it's not what you really learn at school.
Okay. So imagine the fun stuff that machine learning researchers do.
What is that? What is the fun stuff?
What would be fun for me? I think, uh,
in terms of research would be, you know,
investigating the latest, uh, algorithms and like, uh,
understanding why they work, why they don't trying different set data sets on,
um, these new algorithms. A lot of the things that you've seen out there,
like Gans, generative, adversarial networks,
you make like funky images, uh, style transfers,
like these were all investigations and why do convolutional
networks work as they do? Um, and that's research, right.
And that's not, it's not primarily those,
those things were not built primarily for a business.
Yeah. Got it.
And of course, Lisa is an AI for leasing.
One of the problems that people had was like, when you put your, uh, your,
your apartment for, uh, on Zillow or something like that,
you get a ton of inbound. You have, um, you have emails, you have text messages.
Yeah. Phone calls. Like it's the, it's very fragmented.
The things that you get and you have to take all of that inbound
coordinate, showings,
take care of applications and like do all that move in process. Uh,
so Lisa,
what we decided to do was to automate
the responses, uh, to, uh, text messages, emails,
phone calls. And on the other side, we just produced a showing.
So people just had to show up and least the leasing agents just have
to show up and, uh, sell, sell the property.
They didn't have to coordinate and do all that stuff. Uh, and that was the main,
the main focus. Um, other, I think a lot of people liked how, you know,
their phone stopped ringing, uh, after they used, they started using it.
Yeah. Yeah. Cool. Awesome. So what about you?
What did you do in dynasty? Yeah. You worked on DISA, I guess. Yeah, of course.
So originally I was hired for it to do some research because, you know,
I was a researcher, blah, blah, blah. Um, but you know,
nothing turns out as we plan it.
And I decided to take that opportunity to, uh,
dive into ML. Uh, I mean, I had some MLS experiences, uh,
back in college and a little bit, uh, back in my previous job,
but never, uh, deeply.
So I decided to build out the, the ML components, uh,
got into deep learning, learn about, uh, NLP,
which is natural language processing.
And once that core thing was built, uh, you know,
we were still a startup, we just had to do other things. So I, uh,
got myself into software engineering, um, you know,
before that had never done like real software engineering, but under, uh,
our CTO, uh, I was able to learn a lot about,
um, you know, how to build, uh, how to build products and like,
yes, I did software engineering and, uh, product design. Yeah.
Basically you have to do everything at a startup.
[Inaudible] so why, why couldn't other people just do the same thing,
just apply AI to real estate stuff. And then would they be a competitor?
Like how, why, what made dynasty successful?
We also thought that there was going to be competitors. And I think there,
there are, but nobody took the symbol. The exact approach that we did, uh,
which was Lisa would talk to, to prospects, prospects,
being the people who would rent, uh,
they would talk to them without telling them that they it's a bot or anything,
because in reality, we're not fully a bot either. Um,
about 40% of our messages are handled by humans,
who we call operators. The fact that we try to give such a natural,
um, experienced prospect is something that, um,
the clients really liked because in general, um,
people don't like to interact with a bot. Um,
so our conversations look very natural, uh,
because there's a lot of humans that kind of, uh,
that we fall back to when things go wrong. Actually,
I have a funny story about people not liking to interact with bots.
So one, one thing that we measured, um,
was how often would people see a reply when we send
messages back to them, right? It's like reply ratio or whatever.
Initially we would reply instantaneously because, uh, people would message in.
And we were like, Hey, we have a showing at, uh, two 30. Do you want to come?
Like within seconds? And then,
and then people were probably freaked out and replied less
than if we were to wait two minutes, uh, before.
So all the, we can reply very quickly.
Sometimes we wait a minute or two before doing so that's interesting.
So another part that made us successful, I think, uh, was the fact, well,
I think that the biggest, the biggest success was the, the,
the market validation that was done prior to the pivot, but that aside,
uh, another thing was our willingness to just build what
was needed and like not focus on, uh,
technology too much and just get something out, out there, re uh,
get it in front of people,
iterate and build it as simply as possible so that we don't waste
too much energy trying to optimize a system that was not going to exist like
a week later. Yeah. And also these days, AI products that are like very,
uh, already hot. Um,
a lot of people spend a lot of time optimizing that small, uh,
small component, which in retrospect,
like I could have spent more time on that. But if I did that,
I wouldn't have like use my time to build out the product in terms of the
software engineering part. Right. Deciding to say, okay, that's good enough.
And work on, uh, like the most important part for the business,
uh, was, was something was a, was spirit that like everybody had at dynasty.
And I think that really, um, you know,
pushed us beyond the edge.
Can you give me a concrete example of that thing you just described? Like,
what could have you optimized on, like, how did your ML system work as a whole,
what was that part of the ML system that you could have optimized on,
but what did you work on instead to make your product better.
In the backend? The first ML component that we created was,
um, uh, an intent classifier.
So we would take in messages and, uh,
understand what is the intent to classify them as, uh, uh,
one of a few intents, like, do they want to showing, um,
did they accept something like whatever, um.
Actually before we continue, can I just, um,
kind of have a high level overview of what Lisa does, because right now,
I think it's kind of just like a chat bot for leasing. Yep. And then,
is there anything that does, like, how does it interact with the, um,
the operators and also the clients?
Right.
So Lisa is a pretty complicated product in terms of
how you would explain it, like with the components that you understand,
because there's a lot of interactions. One interaction is with the prospect.
Uh, so with, through there, we, it's just a bunch of texts or emails.
The first text comes in, we ask them, uh,
do they want to showing then the CA the, the conversation can go anywhere.
They can ask questions about property. They can like, um, you know,
decide not to do anything. We have to confirm them for the showing.
And like, we asked them how, how it's going.
That's one interaction with the agents, the leasing agents, uh,
we schedule things on their calendar. Uh,
we ask them questions that we don't know the answer of.
We answer the questions that they have for us.
And there's like an interaction with bosses, which bosses.
The bosses real estate agent boss, correct.
Okay. Uh, sometimes the same person, but like often it's not, uh,
they want reporting. Uh, so that's, uh, that's the main interaction.
And then there's our human operators, which, uh,
uses Lisa as like an interface to the outside world.
They have, uh, what we call the command center.
And it's mostly like a, uh, messenger interface,
but like augmented with a lot of information. And also, uh,
they have a concept called the quick action,
which they can quickly find a commonly use action to
reply to prospects. Awesome. Yep.
Okay.
So that means back then real estate agent would have to communicate with the
prospects due to showing scheduled or own showing, manage your own calendar,
but now they actually don't even need to talk to the prospects.
And you just have Lisa that is kind of like a layer in between the swept them
all. And it's really cool.
Till they get to the showing, which I don't, you know,
they want to use their human specialties.
Through the cell, you know? Well, I mean,
one day you could build robots and just replace that too one day. Yeah.
Cool. Okay. So now that we have a good overview, let's go back to, um,
what are de Mol parts that are very specific.
I'm pretty sure there's ML in the quick reply.
There's.
Probably ML in trying to classify what messages there are.
So what were the other stuff that you could,
that you worked on that was better for the business than just optimizing?
Once we got the intent classifiers, we could have know,
tried better models like Burt or Elmo,
like the stuff that came out in 2008, I was really hot.
We could have tried using that to, you know,
gain a few percentage points of accuracy.
Or those models, uh, like NLP models.
Sorry. Okay. Yeah. We used something like pretty simple, like, uh, uh, tech,
CNN, um, for our core models and it worked, it worked fine.
Uh, but like, you know, show, could we have done better? Uh, we're still trying,
uh, so when we have time, but like, there are more important parts, uh,
to work on. Got it. Yeah. Like,
like the question tiger was born out of necessity and like,
they were there were answering the questions over and over again. Um,
so like finding other places to, to,
to package an ML solution is more impactful than trying
to optimize the existing components. Got it. Yeah.
So what do you think most startups make as
mistakes using ML, like water to come mistakes,
startups make using ML,
cause I'm guessing you're comparing your dynasty to other startups.
So how would they do, what would they do wrong?
My guess would be focusing too much on the latest
technology that's out there,
especially the academic literature and trying to apply that
to their business. It takes time to, for academic literature,
to mature for business. And a lot of, uh,
a lot of the literature is sometimes not reproducible.
Um, and that's a common problem. Uh, so like investing too much there, uh,
we'll waste a lot of time. And as a startup, you don't have a lot of time.
Got it. Now.
I heard a lot of people saying that in theory,
the paper sounds great and it works with their dataset,
but applying it as a whole different story. Yeah. Applying, you have to.
So finding a way to apply ML to a business
environment is difficult because you have to specifically
know which problem like business in itself is like many, many problems.
And you have to carve out one specific problem for ML.
It has to be worth it worth the time of research.
You have to be able to find a process that will generate data for that problem.
And once your algorithm is working, you have false positives,
you have false negatives, you have to have a process to handle that.
And then not even including monitoring, like making sure that, uh,
your, your models are, are always, uh,
performing as well as you think they are in our business with Lisa is generally
pretty. It's not too bad because like English generally doesn't change. Uh,
but you know, maybe if you're working on ads or like, uh,
trading your environment will change and your algorithm performance might
decay. And you, you have to like, know about that.
So there's a lot of stuff that happens around that.
It's no small ML components.
So from what I understand,
it seems like it's better to build out your system,
understanding what you have to do,
how to do everything and then identify what are the spots that need ML and then
solve for that rather than some other companies would identify maybe
even an emo problem and then build out a solution like everything
else, which ultimately,
maybe that solution wasn't even that useful for the market anyways. Right.
Okay. Awesome. So do you want to say, yeah.
I think another, uh,
pitfall would be trying to solve too much with ML.
Like there was a, you know, there's a few companies out there that wanted to,
uh,
build personal assistants and it turns out the job of
personal assistant is like extremely difficult and there's like infinite
variation, right. Even in our business of leasing,
we found that it's very subtle taking the,
the very simple example of what's the rent, you know, you think that's, uh,
a simple answer. Uh, it's a simple question at first, but then you had to say,
you think, okay, well actually, what are they talking about?
The one bedroom or two bedroom.
Are they talking about moving now or moving later? Are they talking about, uh,
uh, one, one, one year lease or two year lease? Oh, wait,
are we talking about the,
like about all our properties or like only the ones that are available? Yeah.
There's a lot of intricacies in a, in a simple question just as like,
what is the rent? Yeah.
And I also know it's quite difficult because I'm trying to hire a real
personal assistant and that is still very hard. So I'm guessing, you know,
cause if you can't even solve my problems with a real human,
I don't even know how to start solving, uh,
with the like machine learning model,
because usually I think if something is easy to solve manually,
like a rapid pellets of repetition, then you can kind of replace it with AI.
But yeah. Yeah.
So that's actually one of the guidelines that we have.
If we want to carve out something for the, for ML first,
solve it with humans, see how it works, see how it works,
if it's really repetitive. And like people make, don't make a lot of mistakes,
right? Some heuristics, uh, not even ML and run,
run with it for awhile, handle your handle, your false positives,
handle your false negatives. And then if the system is humming,
then you know, try to increase the accuracy with, uh, with ML.
But without these intermediate steps, like don't even think about it.
So dynasty, are you guys, um, are you guys hiring, you know.
Yes. Yeah. We're definitely hiring, uh, right now, you know, we need a lot of,
uh, good engineers. Um, the,
the way we want to hire is hiring people who have
a decent software engineering experience because we don't currently have
a lot of time to, to bring people up to speed, uh,
because we're still a startup,
even though we were acquired and we want general software engineering
skills,
we think that that will translate well into the ML parts or,
uh, if you focus on, um, you know,
more system reliability or like, um, more product, uh,
but like the core software skill is what we're looking for. Okay.
What kind of technologies would they be working with if they want to be an
applied machine learning engineer?
We, we, we, uh, we use like typical stuff like TensorFlow, uh, you know,
the Python packages and stuff like that. Um, our stack, uh,
on the backend is Java. Again, our pragmatism, we don't,
we don't try to use too many fancy, uh, latest technologies.
We just use what is tried and proven. Uh,
so really that's kind of our core philosophies.
Right. So what would make a good machine learning engineer, a good hire for you?
What kind of skills are not just skills, but, um, attributes,
personal attributes. Yeah.
Uh, willing to dig into the details, understanding the business, uh,
not like focusing too much on, on the ML part. Um, being good at,
uh, software engineering in general at dynasty, not like ML engineers are not,
are not like, Oh, I'm the ML guy. And then you can,
you guys can do like the backend,
like you have to do you have to do the software engineering.
You don't get like an assistant for that. Yeah.
So what's next for you and dynasty in the next five years?
Well, five years is a long time. I mean, uh, just a year and a half ago. Uh,
it was a different business. Yeah. Uh, th yeah,
two years ago it was a different thing. Um, definitely for me, uh,
I want to see Lisa built out to its full potential. Uh, hopefully, you know,
the viewers will, well someday, uh, rented an apartment.
I'd be talking to Lisa. Um, and after that, who knows, uh,
I think I'll be at folio for the foreseeable future. Yeah. Cool. Well,
maybe I'll be building other ML products, hopefully, uh,
finding other ways to apply ML into the real world.
Awesome. Cool. Yeah. Thank you so much.
And I just want to say best of luck to Lisa dynasty and
AppFolio. Um, if they do want to apply to dynasty,
do they have to do it through AppFolio website or is there a separate dynasty
website?
Uh, we are fully under a full fuller now, so you should apply to AppFolio.
Exactly. Yeah. So, and then if you want to prepare for AppFolio,
don't forget to check out tech and bupropion.
I take on take in referral if you're interested in getting ready for interviews.
Okay.
Yeah. I also want to plug my Twitter. M a David J.
Um, a David J. Cool. All right.
Thank you so much for being here. Really appreciate.
It. Thank you for having me. All right.